les libéraux à l'heure des idées des
militants peu nombreux des débats plutôt
rares les troupes libérales choisissent
la continuité et de s’assumer comme
partie de gauche
minimum garantie 4 semaines de congés
payés logement abordable lutte contre
les changements climatiques plusieurs
résolutions adoptées au Congrès
pourraient se retrouver dans le
programme du NPD les Canadiens ont
encore de l'appétit pour des politiques
progressistes selon cette députée
ontarienne la raison pour laquelle on
continue de voir des
politiques c'est le sentiment que la vie
rendu très cher après 1995 nous avons eu
un autre neuf budgets à surplus
vendredi soir l'ancien Premier ministre
Jean-Chrétien vantait les mérite de la
rigueur fiscale mais les militants ont
vu les choses autrement ils ont rejeté
l'idée d'un plan chiffré de retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire certains sont
déçus
à la maison j'ai un budget et je dois
l'équilibrer souligne ce militant du
Québec la responsabilité fiscale doit
rester au cœur du message croit le
ministre de l'innovation
ADN la rigueur budgétaire les
résolutions adoptées au Congrès ne sont
pas contraignantes le parti doit bien
réfléchir à son prochain programme
électoral et éviter de s'alliéner les
électeurs du centre estiment cette
experte c'est la majorité des électeurs
qui sont dans le centre c'est des
électeurs qui disent moi j'aime
certaines choses à gauche certaines
choses à droite puis essayer de faire la
part des choses et cela se retrouve
orphelin en ce moment mais les électeurs
sont tristes ne sont pas en reste assure
le ministre de l'Environnement il y a
beaucoup de choses qui intéressent les
gens au centre notamment les questions
de développement économique d'énergie
renouvelable
les militants choisissent de demeurer
sur la même voie il ne ressentent pas le
besoin d'offrir une vision réinventer du
Parti libéral convaincu d'avoir trouvé
la recette gagnante mais cette approche
ne les aidera pas à se débarrasser de
l'étiquette d'un gouvernement dépensier
que tente de leur coller les
conservateurs ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada Ottawa